the smallest of people facing the
greatest of risks relying on food from
strangers in a foreign land and her
family's intent on taking her on a
dinghy across the channel
not worried about your little one
yeah
i do
why
why
because that is
we see mothers and their children
everywhere doing what they can to stay
warm and telling us about the same
dangerous decision
yes yes
yes i i
this my family going to uk
in the water
but it's very dangerous with the
children
humanitarian groups who are helping
argue hard-line government migration
policies don't work and simply encourage
the smuggling networks
we've seen you know policies of
deterrence of trying to stop people from
assessing here in france i'm trying to
stop them from making those journeys and
and people aren't doing that and
actually you know as british people we
should be proud that people want to come
to the uk that they see it as somewhere
that's safe for them to live and there
should be a certain place that allows
them to do that a safe and legal route
that allows them to do that without
having to risk their lives
the refugees eagerly use charity
charging points to ring home but also to
connect with smuggling groups who take
their money and arrange the sea
yes there are some guys responsible for
that they check the road
if everything is safe i mean the police
are not in the road
they manage everything and both
to fix the boat put everything together
and then they
the migrants carry the boat and
made it to the shore
and they get inside and go
many tell us of several botched attempts
but the life jackets around indicate
future channel trips are still planned
a few people have built their shelters
in the woods
and
quite a few are keeping these on hand
life jackets ready for the next trip
across the channel
among those still planning to make the
trip are unaccompanied children we saw
mostly boys including this 14 year old
seen in the middle of two friends but
who'd fled afghanistan on his own just
before the taliban took power
but this is very dangerous it's very
dangerous yes
1999
will die in the sea
but we should go we don't have other way
we found one 22 year old afghan who's
just arrived in dunkirk now desperately
looking for a way to cross to britain
my father's also he was a policeman in
afghanistan so now he is at home he is
close he cannot go to outside so when i
so i i i see i say for them so when i go
to britannia i will
help you so we we save for the
government to britannia so you help my
family because my father is a policeman
so he cannot
go outside and the
[Music]
he's talking to his brother still in
kabul who tells us the whole family's
future rests on him reaching britain
safely
[Music]
all those we spoke to told us of
traveling and living rough for
weeks a deal showed us where he his wife
and four young children have been
sheltering
the family fled persecution in iraq and
he spent thousands on a smuggling
network openly operating on facebook
again he tells us he has no alternative
of course i'm scared of taking my family
by boat to britain but i've no other
option
it's the root of death but i have to
take
like so many the dangers of making that
terrible journey are eclipsed by the
dangers they're all running from
alex crawford sky news in northern
france